mergault considère que sa carrière a été
facilitée par deux atouts une qualité et
un défaut la qualité une plastique
irréprochable mais font un défaut de
prononciation mais c'est à coup
finissent par là cantonné dans des rôles
qui ne lui conviennent plus alors elle
se ressentent sur l'écriture le théâtre
et la réalisation cinéma après le succès
de son premier film je vous trouve très
beau
elle récidive avec enfin veuve
interprété par michèle laroque et
jacques gamblin les déboires d'une jeune
veuve qui se croit enfin libre et va
découvrir un emprisonnement bien payant
la famille côté scène on retrouve
isabelle mergault dans croque-monsieur
au théâtre des variétés à partir du 24
janvier dans son journal intime
elle rêve d'être un trotteur qui enfin
se met au galop mais sans personne sur
son dos
[Musique]
et c'est terrible les interviews pour
moi j'ai l'impression que ça va
intéresser personne donc je ne
m'intéresse même plus au moment où je
dis ma phrase je m'ennuie déjà avant le
milieu de ma phrase et je m'intéresse
pierre j'adore faire rire mais parler de
moi sauf si j'arrive à trouver un angle
drôle pour en parler oui mais parlez
nous de parler sans faire rire sa mort
j'ai pas eu peur d'emmener tout vient
vite le film eurocup
tu viens faire
bien faire
d es mon père et elle se retient ma mère
médecin puis après ces méfaits de la
recherche
bon moi dans mon enfance j'ai pas
tellement été élevée par des parents
mais surtout par des bonnes parce que
mes parents qui venait d'un milieu assez
modeste avait un vrai désir tous les
deux de de s'élever dans l'échelle
sociale et donc il bossait comme des
malades et je les ai pas vus beaucoup et
ça je sais que ça m'a manqué j'ai eu une
enfance heureuse mais bon je n'ai pas
tellement l'école je me suis fait virer
mais un nombre incalculable de fois et
la première fois que que mes parents
m'ont laissé chez mes grands parents
savaient quatre ans pour les vacances et
c'est du très mal le prendre
et quand quand ils sont venus me
chercher ma mère je lui ai dit qu'elle
est arrivé jeudi en fin au bout d'un
mois je dis bonjour madame et l'appeler
madame pendant toute la journée ce qui
était très très dure pour elle c'est une
façon de punir le soir par et d'avoir le
soir j'ai fait un câlin glück mormon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je déteste ça poster je déteste les
légendes qui arrive en terrain conquis
qui pense que c'est très facile de
peindre de faire de faire un fil de fer
de d'écrire un livre ça ça me semble de
l'imposture quand vous commencez à être
un petit peu connu puis coup vous
propose les treuils faire un disque une
junior à écrire votre vie c'est ni le
vrai métier qui est d'être réalisateur
d'être tombera parce que c'est tellement
bon d'être un artisan de bien c'est
peut-être d'être au liban dans ce qu'on
fait moi je suis bonne dans mes
scénarios
ça a donné un se trouve un bon film
parce que justement c'est pas ici est
allé au delà de mes mots que ses écrits
de mes petites images que j'ai dans la
tête quoi qu'est ce qui se passe non pas
pas eu d'incidents et d'accidents
mortels
oh la la il est blessé mortel en à la
maman mais le chien va bien se fait
toujours plaisir mais scénario se
ressemblent et parlent toutes sortes
d'amour je suis
et moi pourquoi j'ai alors vu une vie
très étroites un jeu pas du tout
intéressantes dans l'avion ont déjà moi
je m'intéresse pas à grand chose
vous me donnez un mot fléchi et moi je
suis contente ça fait ma soirée
impossible de prononcer un seul sens
[Musique]
t
ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup quand je
fais des répétitions ou que je mets des
costumes que s'est créée et pour vous
parler de moi moi du quotidien ça se
voudra j'ai quand même eu un dîner
devait avoir un truc dans mon éducation
que clocher parce que trop bien élevé ou
c'est pas un sourd il y avait un mini
incendie chez moi et ma mère dit sont
censés sont paniqués me direz kouba en
face à l'ogre grise des amis à nous ils
vont passer un extincteur parce que là
la machine a eu un court circuit toubon
qui vais et il y avait trois personnes à
la droguerie j'ai pas pu passer avant
quand j'ai attendu
j'ai fait la queue je me souviens
vraiment j'ai j'ai pris mon courage à
deux mains j'avais mon coeur qui battait
est passé devant les gens jeudi prime
denise secteur parce que là ça commence
à je suis fait engueuler par le
droguiste qui m'a dit mon femme il
fallait il fallait il fallait venir tout
de suite pour les mets mon premier
réflexe a été d'appeler bizarre parce
que sur scène et moi je peux dire l'été
je peux faire n'importe quoi sur ce
point m à oilpé je peux même plus je
peux dire des yeux rouges
c'est bizarre je ne m'explique pas çà çà
çà çà m'a beaucoup troublé cette cette
chose là
[Musique]
je suis jamais jamais jamais jamais mais
je pense que c'est bien que je me sois
jamais aimé parce que sinon je n'aurais
pas écrit
vous savez quand vous êtes enfermé dans
votre bureau pendant quatre mois pour
écrire un scénario
ça veut dire que le supporter est
fatalement la tête que vous avez dans
votre miroir sinon vous feriez autre
chose mais encore une fois je suis
contente d'avoir toujours réussi failli
parce que parce que je sais que c'est ça
qui m'a fait rendre plus drôle pour me
faire accepter pour pour faire rire les
autres
au lieu de jouer sur ce que j'étais moi
tout simplement c'est toujours sur loué
pour me faire accepter un petit peu
partout et c'est très bien que j'ai eu
ce défaut de prononciation parce que ça
m'a fait les mettant en scène tout de
suite se souvenait de moi et tout donc
savez peut-être je marquais tout de
suite par un bonjour taquet comme ça je
le savais j'en étais conscient il sait
jamais j'ai jamais fait exprès d'avoir
ce défaut en revanche souvent fait
exprès de trouver des mots que ce
n'arrivait pas à prononcer est un petit
district au donc je pense que je ne sais
pas si je même de plus en plus puisque
je me suis jamais vraiment aimé mais je
m'accepte de plus en plus
[Musique]
et puisque je suis de plus en plus avec
moi même je dégage fabrique oui mais tu
n'as pas envie mais c'est dans les
chevaux j'adore les courses et ce qui
est intéressant dans le trot c'est
qu'ils peuvent se mettre à la faute
vous sentez que le cheval qui est brimée
il se retient de galoper et là y'a un
moment donné il est positif
il peut rien faut qui galope et je vous
jure que je suis contente pour lui il
s'est évadé pendant quelques temps par
faute c'est la faute
vous avez mille euros dessus que ça fait
cher cet instant de liberté mais aussi
[ __ ] par une bonne manière mon
éducation et ils n'arrivent pas à
galoper ce que j'écris aussi c'est
gentil c'est correct et peut-être qu'un
jour pascal au près et j'écrirai quelque
chose est différent et plus débridé pas
de choquer monsieur tout seul je cours
pas il faut personnes sûrement une
grande page vous a plu
[Musique]